c'est l'heure du second débat de ce sens
public il porte sur les réformes
annoncés ou envisagés par le Président
de la République et son nouveau ministre
de l'Éducation Gabriel Attal
l'interdiction de labaya des vacances
plus courtes pour les élèves en
difficulté le renforcement des savoirs
fondamentaux et bien sûr la dernière
annonce l'expérimentation du port de
l'uniforme à l'école une tenue unique
pour un débat récurrent Jérôme Rabier
c'est un débat que Pape Ndiaye ne
voulait pas ouvrir mais son successeur à
l'éducation nationale compte bien le
lancer dès sa première entrée Gabriel
Attal veut avancer sur le dossier de
l'uniforme à l'école je ne sais pas si
l'uniforme est une solution un peu
miracle qui permettrait de régler les
problèmes de harcèlement d'inégalité
sociale de laïcité et autres ce que je
sais c'est que c'est un débat qui est
présent dans le pays et depuis un
certain temps et moi je pense qu'un
débat il faut toujours le faire
progresser une demande ancienne de la
droite et de l'extrême droite pour
éviter les inégalités vestimentaires
mais également fermez la porte au
vêtements à la frontière du religieux
comme la Baya récemment interdite à la
tête des républicains
ericciotti saluent la mesure et demande
que les Alpes-Maritimes bénéficient de
l'expérimentation comme les mers
rassemblement national de Perpignan et
Béziers le président de la République
veut laisser sa chance à l'initiative
mais pas forcément avec un uniforme trop
strict il y a aussi la tenue unique sans
avoir un uniforme on peut dire vous vous
mettez en jean t-shirt et veste la
question de la tenue unique qui n'est
pas l'uniforme qui à mon avis est plus
acceptable peut paraître un peu moins
strict d'un point de vue disciplinaire
elle règle beaucoup de sujets s'il veut
aller plus loin le gouvernement pourra
s'appuyer sur des propositions de loi
comme celle déjà déposées au Sénat sur
le sujet mais qui vise une
généralisation d'ici là le ministre
précisera à l'automne les modalités
d'une expérimentation dans certains
territoires
plusieurs syndicats d'enseignants
dénoncent les cite une vision pacéiste
de l'école d'Emmanuel Macron on en débat
tout de suite avec Cédric Vial bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes sénateur LR
de la Savoie membre de la commission de
la culture de l'éducation et de la
communication ici au Sénat Laurence
Decock bonsoir bienvenue historienne de
l'éducation enseignante au lycée dans le
supérieur et puis auteur de ce livre
école publié dans la collection le mot
est faible et c'est aux éditions anamosa
William la fleur bonsoir bienvenue alias
Monsieur le prof pour ceux qui vous
suivent sur les réseaux sociaux auteur
de l'ex plus beau métier du monde qui
vient de paraître chez Flammarion prof
d'anglais pendant 12 ans je crois et
vous venez de quitter l'éducation
nationale c'était là il y a quelques
jours bon ben voilà c'est une raconter
tout ça Laetitia cru palitoris politique
est resté à mes côtés alors on va il y a
plein de thèmes à aborder dans ce débat
et on va parler quand même beaucoup de
vêtements je commence par
l'expérimentation de d'une tenue unique
voilà je vais prendre ces termes qui
sont peut-être les plus précis dans
départements Cédric est-ce que vous y
êtes favorable
très honnêtement j'ai des doutes sur
l'efficacité une telle mesure donc je
suis pas radicalement compte je pense
que ça mérite d'être essayé peut-être
qu'il faut expérimenter à titre
personnel je pense que c'est plus un
fantasme qu'une mesure c'est fantasme
c'est quelque chose qu'on idéalise c'est
une mesure quand on pense qu'elle aura
toutes les vertus qu'elle va résoudre
tous les problèmes auxquels on sait pas
à clé ou qu'on a refusé de auquel on a
refusé cette clé et je pense d'ailleurs
que comme tous les fantasmes c'est fait
pour pas être réalisé parce que quand on
les réalise on s'aperçoit que c'est pas
aussi bien qu'on le pensait c'est
efficace et puis surtout après on a plus
d'idéal auquel on pense quoi j'ai peur
que
aujourd'hui on y a plein de problèmes à
l'école on a l'impression que l'uniforme
a tous les résoudre je pense pas que ce
soit le cas après c'est pas forcément
une mauvaise mesure je pense que ça ça
peut être essayé mais il faut
l'expérimenter avant de le rendre
obligatoire et alors c'est d'ailleurs ce
que propose le ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui lui-même moi je l'écoutais
sur RTL si je me trompe il y a deux
jours où il était il disait on va on va
le tester et il disait pas ça va régler
tous les tous les problèmes même d'un
coup de baguette magique Laurence de coq
est-ce que vous dites essayons après
tout ou alors de toute façon ça sert à
rien c'est pas dans notre culture
d'autres pays le font ok mais pas nous
je dis il y a vraiment d'autres
priorités vraiment je pense que c'est un
effet d'annonce qui n'a mais strictement
aucun intérêt si ce n'est celui de
détourner les regards sur des choses qui
sont beaucoup plus importantes
également importantes et puis ce sont
des effets d'annonce celle sur les
uniformes en tout cas qui s'inscrivent
aussi dans un passé c'est à dire que
c'est régulier c'est régulièrement on
nous ressort aussi cette idée d'uniforme
ce qu'il faut voir derrière en fait
c'est un effet de discours et donc en
fait ce que ça charit comme image c'est
l'image d'un moment où l'école a
fonctionné et ce moment un peu
fantasmatique vous avez raison c'est le
moment de l'école de l'école
républicaine des encres violettes de
cette école de Jules Ferry etc ce moment
où il y avait l'autorité du maître même
bien avant encore hors ce moment là
quand on est historien de l'éducation on
sait qu'il n'a jamais existé donc on
voit bien que c'est aussi une façon de
faire passer
une émission je peux dire que
je je véhicule un cliché des histoires
du chahut on en a on en a ça existe et
le chahut c'était c'était très important
mais surtout ce que je veux dire c'est
que c'est que sacharrive une certaine
image de l'école voilà et c'est ça qui
est et c'est ça qui est visé je pense
par la campagne de communication autour
de l'uniforme et cette image de l'école
on a envie de dire stop elle a jamais
existé passons aux choses sérieuses
alors on parlera du reste évidemment
même si on va rester sur des questions
vestimentaires juste après mais j'aurais
aussi vous entendre là-dessus je
commence par le on va dire le plus
pointu et puis ensuite on élargira
évidemment
William Lafleur mais est-ce que ça vous
aurait simplifié la vie vous de temps en
temps que vos élèves et une tunique pas
du tout je vois vos yeux dites moi j'ai
c'est la dernière de vos préoccupations
qui sont les enseignants qui réclament
l'uniforme qui où est-ce que Gabriel
Attal a eu cette idée enfin personne n'a
jamais réclamé ça on s'ana aucun intérêt
effectivement les ados s'habillent déjà
quasiment tous pareils
donc non ça ne va pas résoudre
grand-chose les problèmes qu'on a en
classe ça peut être le comportement ça
peut être la dissipation ça peut être le
manque de moyens évidemment
un vecteur de je sais pas de cohésion au
sein d'un établissement par exemple il y
aura peut-être moins de marqueurs
sociaux d'un élève à l'autre enfin voilà
je porte les arguments de ceux qui
défend la tenue unique j'ai travaillé
dans un établissement anglo-saxon ou
l'uniforme était de rigueur ça ne
m'empêchait en rien de connaître le
statut social ou le des élèves parce
qu'il y avait ceux qui pouvaient changer
d'uniforme tous les jours il y a ceux
qui étaient rapiessés il y a ceux qui
avaient des très belles chaussures ou un
très beau sac donc on a toujours un
moyen de montrer à quel groupe social on
appartient donc ça va à résoudre ça
c'est un marqueur de droite Cédric Vial
est-ce que Emmanuel Macron Gabriel font
un clin d'oeil à la droite en parlant du
rôle
de droite ou républicain mais je pense
qu'on en fait un faux débat parce qu'on
on parle de l'uniforme à chaque fois
qu'on parle de problème de laïcité on
parle d'uniforme à chaque fois qu'on
parle de problème de marqueur sociaux
etc et je pense comme je disais tout à
l'heure que ça ne résoudra pas ses
problèmes ou je suis assez en phase avec
vous je pense que l'uniforme par contre
il peut faire partie de donner un
sentiment d'appartenance à un groupe à
une collectivité donc éventuellement à
une collectivité qui vécu des valeurs et
des valeurs républicaines il faut
vraiment en parlera peut-être et je
pense que c'est ça qui est plus fort en
voile l'image ici quelque part quand
vous faites partie de cette classe vous
voyez tous les élèves
avec le même uniforme ça donne un
sentiment d'appartenance peut-être un
sentiment de fierté avec des
inconvénients peut-être de solidarité et
je pense que s'il y a un effet positif
il est plus à rechercher ici car
chercher là la manière d'éviter de
traiter les autres problèmes
d'inégalités sociales ou de laïcité par
l'uniforme où là je pense que c'est pas
la bonne la bonne porte d'entrée alors
la défense de l'électricité c'est
évidemment l'argument principal qui
justifie et je vous l'avais dit on va
parler beaucoup de vêtements là de
vêtements la décision Gabriela taille il
a annoncé l'interdiction des abeilles à
selon le bilan du ministère dans la
journée d'hier donc rentrée scolaire 298
adolescentes ont bravé l'interdiction ce
lundi 67 ont refusé de retirer leurs
abeilles ils sont rentrés chez elle et
alors pour la secrétaire général du
syndicat SNES FSU c'est drôle c'est un
peu le discours que vous tenez cette
question des abayas là on était sur le
port de l'uniforme de la tenue unique
elle dit la même chose sur les averses
ça doit pas masquer les vrais questions
de la rentrée
on regarde l'ensemble des problèmes que
que connaît enfin des sujets je dirais
que que connaît aujourd'hui l'éducation
nationale passer autant de temps sur les
abayas oui c'est disproportionné voilà
parce que aujourd'hui il y avait il peut
y avoir un sujet dans certains
établissements je l'ai dit on va pas le
on va pas le sous-estimer on va pas le
surestimer non plus et on va quand même
faire une rentrée on va monter de
professeur on va faire on sait que il
faut recruter 329 000 enseignants d'ici
2030 premier degré second degré pour
faire face au départ à la retraite ça
veut dire enfin 2030 c'est demain donc
ça veut dire accélérer sur la question
de l'amélioration de conditions de
travail et de la revalorisation et on
parle des abeilles
alors on reviendra sur le manque de
moyens c'est promis en général dans
cette émission je tiens mais mes
promesses mais là je reste sur la
question des abayas William la fleur je
m'appuie sur votre expérience de
professeur peut-être peut-être des
proviseurs avec lesquels vous travaillez
est-ce que ça va leur simplifier la vie
quand même d'avoir une règle claire
maintenant oui j'imagine qu'avoir au
moins une règle qu'on les laisse pas
faire les choix eux-mêmes c'est d'accord
ça peut les aider mais donc on parle de
300 élèves sur 12 millions ça va aider
quelques chefs d'établissement est-ce
que c'était si peu que ça parce que la
la Sophie vinétite et disait quand même
il faut pas surestimer mais pas
sous-estimer ce qui était en train de se
passer donc il y en a oui 300 sur 12
millions est-ce que c'est peu elle a dit
qu'il avait pris cette mesure aussi
après les remontées il a beaucoup été
voir les principaux les ceux qui
dirigent les établissements scolaires et
donc ce serait une concertation avec les
personnes qui sont responsables de ces
établissements qui auraient eu pour
conséquence cette mesure
c'est ce qu'il dit quand est-ce qu'il
vous allez les voir il a été nommé en
juin les vacances étaient en juillet
dans les établissements dans lesquels je
n'ai jamais eu de problème de tenue
religieuses
éducation nationale mais là on est sur
une question de principe et sur les
principes le but c'est de pas transiger
donc de pas laisser même un petit peu se
développer sous prétexte qu'il y aurait
d'autres choses plus importantes à
traiter on laisserait parce qu'une fois
qu'on les laisse la brèche ouverte on a
déjà perdu c'est une question de
principe la laïcité c'est un principe de
de la République et qui est inscrit dans
la Constitution qu'il y a une loi
aujourd'hui qui est la loi de la loi de
2003 enfin 2004 et 2014 qu'il a qu'il a
détermine on n'a pas changé la règle
d'ailleurs à la rentrée on s'appuie sur
la règle qui est la loi de 2004 qui
permet d'interdire la Baya le seul
problème c'est qu'on a laissé un
flottement et laisser des capacités
d'interprétation au niveau local qui
donnait le sentiment à tous les chefs
d'établissement qui ne serait pas
forcément soutenu dans une position qui
qui pourrait être la leur par leur
hiérarchie là le seul point que
j'estime vraiment positif de cette
rentrée c'est qu'on a donné un signe
politique fort au chef d'établissement
en disant votre hiérarchie vous
soutiendra et appliquez la règle
appliquez la loi votre hiérarchie vous
soutiendra et pour l'instant ça marche
mais c'est le jour de la rentrée on sait
très bien comment ça fonctionne ils vont
laisser passer un peu de temps et on
sait qu'il y aura il y aura d'autres
tentatives tout au long de l'année et on
y consacrera un débat complet dans
quelques jours dans cette émission mais
avec le problème sur l'application pas
seulement une ou deux journées de
d'évaluation et justement si on essaye
de prendre le recul le 11 de quoi que je
m'adresse à l'historienne sur si on peut
faire un bilan de cette loi 2004 sur
l'interdiction alors j'allais dire de
vol islamique mais des signes extérieurs
ostentatoire
finalement ça s'est bien passé mal passé
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez en dire je
peux en dire plusieurs choses d'abord la
première chose c'est que cette loi c'est
l'aboutissement de presque deux ans de
discussion donc c'était quand même une
époque il y a 20 ans où on prenait le
temps de réfléchir à des aspects sociaux
pour ensuite statuer dans un sens ou
dans un autre c'est le produit d'une
commission la commission statique
beaucoup d'auditions beaucoup
d'auditions de chef d'établissement
certains étaient pour certains étaient
contre la commission était très très
partagée par ailleurs et ça a fait débat
dans la société c'est des débats qui ont
aussi filtré dans les médias etc on a
pris notre temps pour en parler
j'insiste là dessus parce que la
question des abayas elle nous est tombée
sur la tête en septembre personne n'y
avait véritablement réfléchi et c'est
simplement en effet une remontée non pas
de rencontres avec des chefs
d'établissement mais de donner dans un
logiciel qui recense qu'on appelle des
atteintes à la laïcité lesquelles ne
sont d'ailleurs pas tout à fait clair
c'est pas vraiment arrivé le concept
donc soyons juste la question de
l'interdiction des abeilles le sujet a
commencé à monter il y avait même des
recensements tous surprises le jour de
la rentrée
maintenant pour reprendre votre votre
question la loi de 2004 elle a elle a eu
des effets dont on n'a pas encore tiré
complètement les bilans elle a eu des
effets je vais très très nuancée elle a
eu des effets positifs dans beaucoup
d'établissements positifs dans le sens
où ça n'est plus ça n'a plus été une
question le port du foulard c'est à dire
voilà les jeunes filles l'ont enlevé
elles l'ont enlevé en entrant et puis
voilà c'est assez apaisé ça n'a plus été
une question au sens moi j'ai connu
j'étais enseignante à Nanterre à cette
époque là où on en parlait pas c'est une
non question et donc la loi était
appliquée la loi était appliquée la loi
a toujours été appliquée mais elle a eu
des effets aussi
qu'on n'a pas encore suffisamment
quantifié qui est le le nombre de jeunes
filles qui ont quitté l'école publique
parce qu'elles souhaitaient garder le
foulard et qui donc sont allés en école
privée et donc aussi des effets de
déscolarisation de jeunes filles dans
les quartiers populaires on n'a pas
encore d'enquête très précise là-dessus
mais c'est un bilan qu'on doit tirer
pour faire véritablement un bilan
objectif de cette loi de 1004 et je
termine juste sur quelque chose là où je
vous rejoins la loi de 2004 permettait
de travailler la question des habayas
autrement que par une interdiction sur
une circulaire qui va peut-être être
retoquée par le tribunal administratif
d'ailleurs on n'en sait rien elle
permettait de la travailler en prenant
son temps voilà et ça ça n'a pas été un
choix qui a été ce qui est sûr c'est que
cette approuvé par une large majorité
transsexe si l'on en croit notamment ce
sondage
ifope pour Charlie Hebdo 81% des
personnes interrogées approuvent la
décision d'interdire le port de la Baya
ça explique peut-être aussi le choix de
Gabriel Attal on en parle tout de suite
avec Tam être un ami qui me rejoindre
sur ce plateau rebonsoir Tam Gabriel
Attal dont on va parler maintenant
fait-il de l'anti Pap Ndiaye sur cette
question des abayas c'est un sujet
labaya qui en tout cas rythmé le bref
passage de papel Ndiaye à l'éducation
nationale une année et de nombreuses
temporisation de la part de l'ancien
ministre une année et de nombreuses
questions d'actualité au Sénat poser
souvent à la droite de l'hémicycle sur
ce sujet retour au mois de novembre 2022
le ministre est interpellé à deux
reprises sur la Bahia écoutez monsieur
le ministre face à ces dérives répétées
en Montauban comme ailleurs allez vous
clairement indiquer que le port de la
Baya est une Athènes délibérée au
principe de laïcité et n'a pas sa place
à l'école à propos de ces abayas il y a
une loi c'est la loi de 2004 et le
législateur avait précisément prévu que
différentes
itérations de vêtements à intention
religieuse pourrait se produire par la
suite le caractère de cette loi c'est
que c'est une loi à dimension générale
qui s'applique à de multiples situations
et par conséquent nous notre boussole
c'est de faire observer la loi la loi de
2004 vous en avez parlé sur ce plateau
qu'est-ce qu'elle dit exactement elle
dit dans les écoles les collèges et les
listes les publics le port de signe ou
tenu par lesquels les élèves manifestent
ostensiblement une appartenance
religieuse est interdite bien sûr pas de
mention explicite de la Baya et donc une
loi insuffisante aux yeux de certains
sénateurs retours de l'éducation
nationale sur la bailleur regarde la loi
vous n'avez pas répondu monsieur le
ministre est-elle considérée comme une
manifestation ostensible d'appartenance
religieuses d'un point de vue juridique
la Bayane est pas simple à définir nous
serions contournés la semaine suivante
par une longueur de robe par une forme
de colle par tel ou tel accessoire qui
prolongerait de semaine en semaine et
multiplierait les circulaires et nous
emmènerai directement au tribunal
administratif et nous perdrions tribunal
administratif voilà l'ex-ministre rabot
se dire ferme sur le sujet le refuse
donc de définir et d'interdire la Baya
anticipant un échec devant le tribunal
administratif justement est-ce qu'il a
évolué lors de son passage au
gouvernement sur cette question pas
voilà ce qui nous disait au mois de juin
écoutez nous n'allons pas éditer un
catalogue de centaines de pages avec des
formes de manches ou de couleur on ne
s'en sortirait pas d'un point de vue
juridique effectivement l'appréciation
du caractère religieux ou pas ce sont
les chefs d'établissement qui doivent la
porter notez quand même temps le
ministre dit à plusieurs reprises qu'il
n'a pas la main qui tremble mais sa
position est interprétée comme un nouvel
atermoiement les chefs d'établissement
réclament des consignes claires les
voilà donc en position d'arbitre
souverain les décisions de Gabriel Attal
on comprend elle tranche vraiment avec
celle de son prédécesseur au niveau de
la forme au niveau du fond on a bien
tourné la page papendaye rue de Grenelle
là je pouvais plutôt la défense sur ces
sujets Gabriel Attal s'est montré très
offensif il a même manœuvré pour que
l'on ne parle que de la Baya en cette
rentrée c'est réussi un thème qui divise
à gauche et sur lequel la droite ne peut
que lui apporter son soutien elle qui a
réclamé tout de même toute l'année
dernière on l'a entendu l'interdiction
de la Baya hier voilà Emmanuel Macron
qui a défendu lui aussi l'interdiction
de la Baya prenait une application
stricte de la laïcité reste un zigzag
gouvernemental un grand zigzag entre le
mois de juin et cette rentrée comme s'il
exécutif avait oublié toutes ses
positions passées pendant les grandes
vacances merci beaucoup Tam traduit au
Cédric je me tourne vers vous sur cette
hypothèse effectivement tribune à un
escatif risque de voir les décisions et
cette interdiction cassée qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez mais moi je serais pas
aussi dur que beaucoup de mes collègues
sur papel Ndiaye parce que je pense
qu'il est son plus gros défaut ça pas
été
conciliant avec les abayas c'est d'avoir
été conciliant avec ses services
probablement parce que les associations
les services du ministère week-end ce
genre de discours juridique pour dire
mais il faut faire attention etc et donc
faut pas faire de vagues et on renvoie
la décision au niveau local sur les
chefs d'établissement c'est plutôt un
manque de courage politique que c'est ça
je pense qu'on a retrouvé chez Gabriel
Attal sur sur ce point-là la loi est
encore une fois elle est très claire sur
les recours devant les tribunal
administratifs oui il y en aura
probablement mais aujourd'hui je
pense qu'en tout cas sur les premiers
cas on n'aura pas trop de difficultés la
loi elle est assez clair et vous l'avez
cité tout à l'heure elle fait une phrase
tout signe d'appartenance tout signe
ustensiles d'appartenance religieux
c'est pas le fait de savoir si le
vêtement est un vêtement religieux ou
pas ils auraient un t-shirt marqué je
suis musulman ou je suis catholique ce
serait interdit de la même façon on n'a
pas le droit d'avoir un signe d'apparter
entre les jeux à partir du moment c'est
un vêtement qui n'est porté que par des
gens qui sont qui ont cette origine ou
cette ou cette religion c'est un signe
d'appartenance fin du film là où il n'a
pas complètement tort et on verra plus
tard c'est qu'il y aura probablement des
gens qui essaieront de contourner la
règle et contourner la probablement que
ça arrivera ce que je disais tout à
l'heure le problème n'est pas
complètement clos allez on va sortir de
ces débats on va dire vestimentaires
mais si évidemment beaucoup de de
symboles derrière cette décision
peut-être sur le fait de voir comme ça
de ministre
cette sorte de zig-zag
pour des professeurs comment c'est vécu
ça d'avoir une doctrine et puis six mois
après huit mois après quelque chose de
presque inverse et que ce soit sur les
programmes ou sur justement la vie
quotidienne à l'école c'est assez
frustrant mais on a la même chose quand
on a un nouveau chef d'établissement
dans qui arrive c'est qu'il veut imposer
sa marque donc il veut se différencier
du précédent mais ce qu'on remarque
c'est sur surtout les ministres depuis
20 ans ils ont la même politique
derrière donc sur ces choses très
secondaires on va avoir des différences
mais sur la politique d'économie de
baisser le nombre d'heures des dotations
rares globales sur le manque de moyens
etc là ils ont la même politique c'est
prendre les embauches restreindre le
l'augmentation du salaire avec le gel du
point d'indice sur ça ils ont une
politique très nette c'est-à-dire que
vous j'essaye de parce que là vous c'est
l'histoire d'une démotivation et
finalement vous êtes dit moi je veux
plus de cette vie de profs oui pas que
mais entre autres je pars on va pas en
état d'entrer dans l'état mais la
première question que vous vous posez le
matin en arrivant c'est quoi c'est
est-ce que est-ce que la classe sera
chauffée en hiver est-ce que
l'ordinateur va fonctionner enfin c'est
c'est aussi basique entre guillemets et
important que ça oui oui c'est des
choses toutes bêtes est-ce qu'on va me
changer ma salle parce que changement de
salle implique beaucoup de modifications
et ce que je vais pouvoir faire court
dans des des conditions de descente rien
que ça est-ce que il va pleuvoir dans ma
salle parce que ça arrive aussi est-ce
que la ESH qui est alors l'adulte qui
est l'aide aux élèves en situation de
handicap qui par ailleurs sont payés en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté il faut le
rappeler donc qui viennent aider les
élèves voilà en situation handicap si
elle est là donc j'en avais une année
dernière qui m'a beaucoup aidé qu'il y
avait un élève hyper actif qu'elle
arrivait à cadrer moi quand j'avais 28
autres élèves à gérer je pouvais pas ça
devenait le bazar donc est-ce qu'elle
est là ouf elle est là je vais pouvoir
faire court plus facilement est-ce que
votre salaire a été un des premiers
critères dans votre décision non je
dirais que c'était plutôt le critère
final en fait c'est un métier où on
encaisse beaucoup de choses on se dit
bon les conditions de travail les élèves
par classe ça augmente c'est compliqué
bon ça fait 8 ans que je suis en région
parisienne j'ai pas envie de vivre là
c'est le jeu mais ok j'encaisse bon les
parents sont de plus en plus derrière
nous sur notre dos à contester les notes
à contester les punitions bon les élèves
c'est pas facile de gérer ils sont 36
bon et en plus la société me méprise et
par de la fin je suis pas bien payé donc
oui qui disait ça hier juste je cite
l'ancien ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui disait que finalement les
profs était des bourgeois qui vivaient
comme des prolétaires
d'où cette frustration et donc ce départ
est cette désaffection pour la
profession vous êtes nombreux dans votre
cas vouloir partir et puis genre jouer
dans dans la présentation de votre livre
que c'est même un parcours du combattant
de quitter l'éducation nationale c'est
pas si simple oui alors on est nombreux
le nombre de démission augmenté de 528%,
ce n'est pas rien et on peine en plus à
recruter donc c'est il y a vraiment un
désamour du métier et en plus
effectivement vu qu'il y a cette pénurie
de prof on peut nous refuser notre
démission parce que on ne pose pas une
démission on demande une autorisation à
démissionner dans l'éducation nationale
et on peut ne la refuser et ça arrive
régulièrement pour ce qu'on appelle
nécessité de service c'est à dire qu'il
y a tellement de profs qui ne peuvent
pas les laisser partir mais sauf que moi
j'ai envie de partir on va pas me forcer
à rester si vous venez pas qu'est-ce qui
se passe alors je suis obligé de faire
un abandon de poste et c'est à dire
mettre les élèves en situation où ils
n'ont pas de professeur pendant des
semaines les pénaliser peut-être que
c'est une façon entre vous et la
direction jusqu'à
votre retour d'expérience sur ces voilà
là on a commencé par l'uniforme ensuite
la Baya on est sur peut-être des
principes peut-être pas le le quotidien
des professes que vous faites un peu le
même constat que oui complètement
complètement moi je suis absolument
atterrée de ce qui est en train de
devenir l'éducation nationale
moi j'ai commencé à enseigner et
maintenant il y a pas mal de temps
jamais on entendait parler de démission
de collègues on avait déjà des problèmes
on était déjà compatible il y a une
culture de la résistance j'ai commencé
en 97 j'étais bébé prof 97 mais non mais
donc même voilà sur un temps finalement
assez court
la dégringolade et un livre comme
celui-ci je n’ai pas souvenir d'avoir lu
l'équivalent il y a 10 ans il y a 15 ans
l'ex plus beau métier du monde
c'est intéressant ce que ce William
parce que pourquoi est-ce qu'on
abandonne pas son poste parce qu'en fait
ce métier on l'aime quand même on laisse
pas 30 gammes engagées voilà c'est à
dire que tout le discours aussi de la
société sur ses profs absentéistes parce
que ça c'est quand même dingue aussi
tout le discours sur le remplacement des
enseignants juste je termine
tendrez à faire penser que on s'en fiche
un petit peu voilà on fait ce métier là
comme ça on va on étire en flan on va
faire notre boulot on n'a pas beaucoup
d'heures 1800
alors qu'en revanche moi je connais pas
d'enseignants qui se job non c'est bon
j'abandonne mes élèves rien à faire etc
voilà ça ça reste et donc ça veut dire
aussi que ce que les responsables de la
décadence de cette de cette institution
et de la et de la et de la décadence du
métier de l'image du métier c'est
vraiment les politiques ce sont des
choix politiques ce sont pas les
individus qui entrent dans le métier
alors on va revenir à la question sur le
les valeurs les choix de du gouvernement
d'Emmanuel Macron parce qu'il y a ces
critiques des syndicats de profs sur
vision pacéiste ou pas de l'école je
voudrais quand même vous entendre sur
cette question des moyens parce que
c'est vrai qu'on se dit on devrait enfin
on devrait les politiques devraient ou
auraient dû commencer par ça est-ce
qu'on a pas finalement toujours été
plutôt dans une logique d'économie on
pourrait avoir ce discours là d'ailleurs
sur l'hôpital aussi
appliqué à l'école
oui alors c'est pas qu'une question de
moyens je pense vous l'avez cité sur son
le la base line de votre livre l'ancien
plus beau métier du monde on pourrait
quasiment dire la même chose pour le
métier d'infirmière aujourd'hui vous
l'avez dit il y a un problème
d'attractivité et puis un problème de
d'exercice du métier qui a qui a changé
pour prendre permettait de préjugés mais
même encore ma génération toutes les
petites filles elle voulait être
maîtresse ou infirmière parce que
c'était des métiers qu'on idéalisait sur
lequel on avait une vision
une vision particulière d'un beau métier
qui était valorisé etc aujourd'hui on a
perdu cette attractivité l'envie de
devenir enseignant ou l'envie de
travailler dans le secteur de la santé
est en train de tomber parce que l'image
l'image du métier reprend pendant des
interrompre ce que disait le 11 de coque
quelle est la part de responsabilité des
politiques et là je vais pas pointer
votre famille politique plus qu'une
autre mais quelle est la part de
respecter collective des gouvernements
qui sont succédés je pense que c'est sur
la deuxième partie qui est sur les
conditions d'exercice qu'on offre à ces
métiers alors il y a c'est une question
moyen mais en même temps quand on
regarde aujourd'hui la vague de
démission et le le depuis 2019 il y a
une chute de de du nombre de candidats
au poste et c'est pas forcément la
période de depuis laquelle le nombre de
moyens par par élève a baisser c'est
plutôt le compteur on a moins on a moins
d'effectifs les effectifs baisse c'est
pas forcément quand on regarde les cours
par exemple maintenant on a on a doublé
les les classes plus facile d'exercer le
métier d'enseignant pour autant mais il
y a quand même eu des progrès qui ont
été fait vous l'avez dit un peu tout à
l'heure aujourd'hui ça devient de plus
en plus difficile d'exercer le métier on
a des enfants qui sont aussi de plus en
plus difficile moi j'ai beaucoup
travaillé sur la question des avsh le
malaise enseignant il vient aussi des
conditions d'exercice du métier alors
oui par des moyens supplémentaires
humains ou ou c'est pas seulement ça non
c'est pas seulement ça si on pense que
c'est qu'une question de moyens on passe
encore à côté du problème il y a
vraiment une question d'organisation il
y a une question de management on
pourrait parler des questions des
mutations on en parlait tout à l'heure
il y a il y a aussi le la mobilité qui
va avec la fonction qui devient une
contrainte dans les nouvelles
organisations familiales qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui qu'on connaissait pas il y a
30 ans en arrière c'est vraiment les
conditions d'exercice dans son ensemble
les moyens permettent d'améliorer les
conditions d'exercice dans certains cas
mais ce n'est pas qu'une question moyen
vous l'avez dit la rémunération bien sûr
les enseignants ont besoin d'être mieux
rémunérés mais comme c'est rarement la
première motivation des gens pour
devenir enseignant et c'est rarement la
première motivation pour lesquelles on
quitte le métier on a parlé de Gabriel
Attal mais c'est Emmanuel Macron qui
donne le la en quelque sorte de cette
rentrée scolaire il l'a fait des lami
août avec une longue interview c'est un
confrère du magazine Le Point il parle
d'autorité de l'instruction civique dont
il veut doubler les heures de programme
des vacances trop longues qui voudraient
écourter notamment pour les élèves en
difficulté le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est que les les syndicats
d'enseignants n'ont pas aimé cette
interview il dénonce je les cite la
vision passéiste de l'école d'Emmanuel
Macron et s'inquiète de la tonalité
sujet conservatrice du discours
présidentiel en matière
d'éducation alors je voudrais vous
entendre la dessus est-ce que vous avez
j'imagine lu cette interview dans le
point le reste de quand je commence avec
vous est-ce que vous aussi vous dites
c'est un discours passéiste ah oui
pourquoi
passeriste et en même temps
novateur dans un sens qui n'est pas
forcément le bon mais il n'est pas que
passéiste alors il est passéiste parce
qu'il envoie effectivement des signaux
du type instruction civique rien que le
terme instruction civile on parle plus
d'instruction civique depuis plus de 50
ans donc on dit enseignement moral et
civique maintenant instruction civique
ce que je disais tout à l'heure c'est
l'école de Jules Ferry vous voyez donc
il y a ça bien sûr le retour de l'hôtel
consacrées
ça vous fait un petit sourire ah quand
j'étais enfant l'instruction civique
c'est ça en fait que ça réveille pareil
pour la question d'autorité
d'un peu plus de de je sais pas de de
d'heures de cours autour de ces
questions de civisme dans les écoles
français c'est une autre question que
vous me posez mais le fait de renforcer
les gens on va doubler les heures de
programmes c'est parce qu'il y en a
besoin potentiellement si je me mets à
la place du président instruction
civique nous
on défend à
défendre ou l'éducation civique
instruction éducation c'est pas la même
chose pour aussi être l'objet d'un débat
donc vous me demandez si c'était
passéiste on a effectivement plusieurs
signaux qui montrent qu'effectivement il
y a quelque chose de passéiste mais dans
les termes mais il y a pas que ça par
exemple Emmanuel Macron c'est aussi une
vision de l'école très start-up donc
l'innovation pédagogique qui va
conditionner un financement plus
important que dans une autre école et
puis là il y a une troisième chose qui
s'est ajoutée qui est passéiste pas
passé j'en sais rien mais dangereuse ça
c'est certain c'est cette volonté de
reciviliser puisque le terme est utilisé
dans la dans l'interview du point à la
suite des émeutes de juillet il dit
voilà l'école va aussi servir un projet
de recivilisation de la jeunesse et là
permettez-moi de me dire que de vous
dire que ça ça m'inquiète un petit peu
voilà que l'école soit mise
voilà au service de ce de ce projet là
c'est pas que passeriste mais ça mais
c'est pas non plus forcément très
progressiste je vais vous poser une
question sur la formation des provenants
dans un instant lié à ces enjeux
d'autorité mais qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez quand Emmanuel Macron dit il faut
restaurer l'autorité des savoirs et
l'autorité des maîtres ce sont les
termes qui l'emploient aussi les mots
ont leur importance oui mais là aussi on
se gargarise un petit peu de mots moi je
vous rejoins
vous étiez Luc Ferry tout à l'heure il
avait une autre phrase il disait que
l'éducation doit toujours posséder
l'instruction l'éducation c'est le rôle
des parents et on a tendance à
considérer que les parents délègue à
l'éducation nationale leur rôle de
d'éducateur le rôle de gestionnaire
c'est l'instruction il faut les deux et
c'est pas parce qu'on va augmenter des
cours d'éducation civique ou morales à
l'école que la situation va s'améliorer
oui il faut restaurer de l'autorité mais
c'est pas parce qu'on va faire des cours
d'éducation civique en disant que
l'autorité est importante quelle va
s'appliquer comme par magie dans les
établissements il faut des principes et
il faut les faire appliquer ces
principes c'est surtout ça et pour qu'on
doit faire appliquer ces principes pour
permettre aux enseignants de pouvoir
faire
de travail c'est à dire enseigner dans
des bonnes conditions les principes
c'est quoi c'est justement c'est
l'autorité c'est le respect c'est la
discipline c'est la laïcité pourquoi on
fait tout ça autour de la laïcité du
respect de la discipline tout simplement
pour donner des conditions favorables
aux enseignants pour enseigner et c'est
le rôle de l'école c'est d'enseigner à
mon avis on lui a donné beaucoup trop de
missions et c'est pour que ça
qu'aujourd'hui là aussi des difficultés
à faire à faire son métier c'est à dire
apprendre aux enfants ce qu'elle doit
leur apprendre parce qu'on lui a confié
toutes les tâches celles qu'on donnait
avant aux parents aujourd'hui on doit
éduquer à la sécurité routière on doit
éduquer à l'égalité entre tout forme
d'égalité au respect à l'écologie etc on
va peut-être même faire des examens
là-dessus à un moment donné il faut
recentrer l'école sur ces missions et il
faut redonner des conditions d'exercices
aux enseignants sereine dans leur classe
je voudrais votre retour d'expérience
sur la formation parce que vous racontez
dans votre livre que voilà vous avez des
collègues qui voilà qui venaient de
passer le CAPES d'ici super des années
des
[Musique]
mais là on est dans l'éducation
nationale on est dans un métier où moi
j'ai des collègues j'ai créé un groupe
d'entraide on est plus de 17000 donc il
y a une vraie demande c'est uniquement
pour les profs d'anglais et on en a à la
veille de la rentrée qui disent personne
ne m'a aidé à faire des cours j'ai le
CAPES j'ai fait deux ans de formation je
n'ai pas de cours à l'aide mais plutôt
que de faire des tours en spaghetti
peut-être qu'on pourrait aider sur cette
question de l'autorité il y a par
exemple ça vous est arrivé de il y a
enfin vous le racontez des des menaces
une forme de violence verbale physique
mais dans ces cas-là vous allez voir le
proviseur qu'est-ce qui se passe
non le proviseur il est dans son bureau
il a autre chose à faire alors moi dès
le premier jour où j'ai enseigné j'avais
face à moi un élève je fais l'appel je
le regarde je dis son prénom il me dit
qu'est-ce que tu me regardes avec ta
beuvard baisse les yeux donc voilà dès
le premier jour il me teste alors bon il
se trouve que j'ai un petit sens de la
répartie je lui ai dit mais si tu es
jaloux de ma Babar t'inquiète pas ça va
pousser dans quelques années le thon est
un peu descendu mais ensuite je suis
allé voir le CPE tout ça pour demander
qu'est-ce que je fais il m'a dit j'ai
hésité à l'exclure il m'a dit mais tu as
bien fait de pas l'exclure un élève ne
doit être exclu que si il y a un risque
avéré de violence bon c'est quand même
assez limité c'est au moment où tolère
j'allais dire l'insulte mais ça vous
l'avez vécu aussi contre qui que ce soit
on tolère l'insulte on dit surtout il y
avait ça #pite vague vous l'avez vécu
vous pouvez en témoigner de ça oui bien
sûr donc le pas de vagues qui est c'est
institutionnalisé c'est l'idée que quand
on subit une agression de la part d'un
parent ou d'un élève il faut surtout
étouffer l'affaire et que si on s'en
plaint à notre chef d'établissement mais
plutôt que nous aider il va peut-être
nous écraser c'est à dire que il va nous
dire mais vous n'avez pas assez
d'autorité c'est de votre faute ou il
vous a juste insulté l'année dernière il
a agressé quelqu'un ça va il y a pire
elle est pas porter plainte il fait des
efforts ce genre de choses donc ça
c'était hashtag a été utilisé je crois
18000 fois par des collègues pour parler
voilà de leur situation vraiment
impossible à tenir et la réaction du
ministère ça va juste de créer la loi
pour l'école de la confiance et de
renforcer le devoir de réserve
c'est-à-dire de museler les enseignants
parce que si on les empêche de parler
ben alors le problème disparaît alors on
va continuer de
d'analyser très vite parce que le temps
a le temps à sur l'autorité vous dit
vous sur la formation des enseignants où
j'ai aussi beaucoup témoignages aux
explique aux enseignants en formation
qu'aujourd'hui un élève dans la classe
qui a besoin de bouger de se lever etc
il faut surtout le laisser faire et donc
on prévoit même des espaces dans la
classe ou pendant le cours il peut se
lever pour aller pour aller faire
d'autres activités parce que aujourd'hui
c'est c'est prendre en compte les
besoins de l'élève et parallèlement à ça
on parle de l'autorité de l'enseignant
et ça c'est dans les organismes de
formation aujourd'hui ce qu'on enseigne
aux enseignants allez on va terminer sur
d'autres annonces faites par le
gouvernement notamment Gabriel Attal
c'était ce matin sur BFM TV là on parle
de renforcer les savoirs fondamentaux on
écoute le ministre
on a besoin de renforcer dans notre pays
ce qu'on appelle les savoirs
fondamentaux et savoir fondamentaux
c'est les savoirs qui permettent tous
les autres c'est le français et les
mathématiques si vous maîtrisez pas la
lecture l'écriture vous aurez du mal en
histoire-géographie ou dans d'autres
matières si vous maîtrisez pas les
mathématiques si vous savez pas compter
vous aurez du mal en physique-chimie et
dans d'autres matières qu'est-ce qu'on
constate aujourd'hui un élève sur trois
qui rentre en 6e ne maîtrise pas
pleinement les fondamentaux un élève sur
trois qui rentre en 6e à des difficultés
de lecture d'écriture ou de calcul et
donc oui j'ai dit que je voulais un choc
des savoirs un choc des savoirs
fondamentaux c'est-à-dire mettre le
paquet renforcer notre action sur ses
savoir-faire notamment en primaire
Gabriel je le rappelle le plus jeune
ministre de l'éducation nationale de la
5ème République il a 34 ans est-ce qu'il
a réussi sa rentrée Laetitia écoutez
globalement
alement vous pourquoi je dis oui et
pourquoi j'ai dit globalement parce que
ça dépend de du point de vue que l'on
prend alors au plan politique et
médiatique oui c'est réussi pourquoi
parce qu'il est partout depuis mi-août
on va dire il fait des déplacements et
il a choisi de se présenter au
professeur au corps enseignant et puis
au monde de l'éducation nationale mais
aussi en français dans les habits du
ministre de l'éducation qui se déplace
qui va sur le terrain donc c'est pas
uniquement de la communication politique
ce ne sont pas que des mots il se
déplace encore aujourd'hui cet
après-midi et était avec Emmanuel Macron
dans les Pyrénées-Atlantiques et ils
refusent de commenter l'action de ses
prédécesseurs Jean-Michel Blanquer papel
Ndiaye lui dit juste le message est très
clair il a dit qu'il allait délocaliser
son ministère il l'a dit au Figaro
pendant quelques jours pour justement ne
pas être le ministre qui prend toutes
les décisions depuis Paris donc le
messager est clair il dit au corps
enseignant je vais être à votre écoute
et je vais être à vos côtés sur les
questions de laïcité on l'a dit la
première mesure c'est l'interdiction de
la ça c'est lui c'est Emmanuel Macron
qui est aux manettes qu'est-ce que vous
en savez de ça c'est absolument pas
Gabriel Attal c'est une décision qui a
été prise à l'Elysée c'était Emmanuel
Macron qui est aux manettes il l'a dit
dans le coin il l'a répété hier soir sur
YouTube
face à Hugo travers il a dit que
l'éducation nationale l'école était sa
priorité il le dit aussi régulièrement
dans tous les communications que nous
recevons nous journalistes c'est dit en
première phrase c'est la priorité
d'Emmanuel Macron à l'école donc pour
Gabriel pas Attal c'est pas si simple
que cela Thomas parce que finalement il
se retrouve à 34 ans oui plus jeune
ministre sous la République de
l'éducation nationale mais il est
chaponné par le Président de la
République est-ce que ça veut dire qu'en
cas de discorde c'est justement Emmanuel
Macron qui reprendra la main en quelque
sorte sur ces questions ce sera coup
l'enjeu de les prochains mois est-ce que
en fonction du dissensus on va voir s'il
dit ça suce est très très grand à
beaucoup d'ampleur peut-être que Manuel
Macron oui répondra directement où se
servira de Gabriel Attal comme éclaireur
voire comme characanau on verra bien il
nous reste quelques minutes le temps à
filer vite ce qui est plutôt bon signe
dans un débat le 11 de quoi que sur ces
savoirs fondamentaux là dont parle le
ministre est-ce que oui ou non là aussi
on va essayer de prendre un peu de recul
ils ont été délaissés ces dernières
années franchement les premiers à avoir
utilisé peut-être je me vends ça mais en
tout cas de mémoire celui qui a utilisé
l'expression savoir fondamentaux je
crois que ça remonte à deux Robiens donc
on est au tout début des années 2000
donc en fait ça fait là aussi plus de 20
ans que c'est un discours qui revient
qui revient régulièrement et sans doute
ça a été utilisé avant moi j'ai rien
contre le fait de dire que
l'entrée dans la lecture dans l'écriture
et dans le calcul est fondamental enfin
je veux dire évidemment que c'est
fondamental la classe de CP c'est une
classe clé alors c'est pas la classe la
plus importante mais c'est une classe
clé dans laquelle un élève est censé
apprendre les rudiments de la lecture et
du calcul et de la logique mathématique
on est tout à fait d'accord avec ça donc
qu'il faille mettre le paquet sur ce
type d'enjeu c'est à dire sur le fait de
faire entrer des enfants dans le savoir
dans la maîtrise de la lecture et
d'écriture ça me semble vraiment de bon
sens mais qu'on le fasse qu'on le fasse
vraiment c'est à dire que on recrute des
enseignants et qu'on les forme comme il
faut alors moi je vais pas rentrer dans
les débats sur beaucoup plus modérée sur
la critique des inspects parce que je
crois qu'il faut vraiment ce qu'ils
peuvent mais en revanche ce qu'il faut
quand même dire c'est qu'aujourd'hui un
étudiant qui veut devenir enseignant en
Master 2 puisque c'est un bac + 5 en
Master 2 il doit remplacer donc il fait
un mi-temps il doit faire un mémoire il
doit passer un concours ça n'est pas une
formation ça apprendre à lire à un
enfant ça aujourd'hui on en parlait tout
à l'heure dans certains quartiers
populaires jour de la rentrée on en est
au stade où c'est le remplaçant du
remplaçant en classe de CP qu'est-ce qui
va faire on recrute des profs en job
dating au bout de 45 minutes comment
est-ce qu'ils peuvent apprendre comment
est-ce qu'ils peuvent apprendre à dire
aux enfants malheureusement j'avais vous
redonner la parole mais on fait signe
que non c'est la fin du débat donc je
suis bien obligé de d'interrompre cette
émission merci à tous d'y avoir
participé c'était passionnant je vais
rappeler les titres de vos livres
Laurence Decock école qui est publiée
dans la collection le mot est faible aux
éditions anamosa et puis William Lafleur
on en a parlé de votre livre l'ex plus
beau métier du monde qui vient de
paraître chez Flammarion voilà je vous
dis à demain pour un nouveau numéro de
sens public on se retrouve tous les
jours sur le canal 13 de la TNT 18h et
22 heures belle soirée